uh next question there a gentleman who
says he's an engineer final year would
be graduate student his final year
examination lies in the month of Ramadan
we were talking about last Ramadan I
believe his mother and his parents have
advised him not observe the fast during
the month of Ramadan because it may
affect his examination results is he
Exempted from fasting on this basis a
person who does not want to fast only
because of the examination it is not a
valid reason even though it may be a
final exam and maybe the parents make
cooks that don't fast because if you
fast then maybe your concentration will
go down and the results will become less
even if the parents Force at this point
of time the child the son or the
daughter should not listen to the
parents because if the parents tell you
something which is against the teaching
of Allah and his scho that's the only
time where they can disobey the parents
Allah says in the Quran in Surah ankabut
29 verse number 8 as well as in Surah
lman chapter number 31 verse number 15
that if your parents Force you or strive
do Jihad to make you worship somebody
else besides Allah subhana wa taala do
not obey them but yet live with them
with love and companionship so here
Quran gives you permission because that
is not a legitimate reason that because
the examination is there they don't want
to fast so that they can get good marks
getting marks in the doing a far is more
important that is the reason this is not
a valid reason and the person should yet
fast inshallah Allah will help him and
he will do better in the examination the
help of Allah is more important than any
other help and Allah says in the Quran
in Imran chapter number three verse
number6 if Allah helps you none can
overcome you if Allah forsakes you who
is there then who can help help you so
let the Believers put their trust in
Allah subhana tala so my advice is that
even if examination let them fast
inshallah the concentration better and
they'll get better marks inshallah